foreign
[Music]
okay so as I illustrate this for you try
to figure out the crime okay
you might you might get enough hints to
do that so here's a setting a British
police officer right standing in court
before the judge and this police officer
sobbing female okay she's crying well
the other chicks always stop
so there's a possibility this police
officer is going to be removed from the
force over something she did
she's crying about it and
um it's something she did
while she was off duty and later lied
about
he borrowed the police outfit as her
costume at the strip club and then
they're like you can't be using like
that for your own personal game two for
two right now and yeah
has an x-com boyfriend or like a calm
like a wanted boyfriend
um okay that's what I was gonna say yeah
like he's he's actually like she's
hiding a criminal yeah oh okay aiding
and abetting well that's feeding him
information right
um stuff like that I think the real one
is probably uh someone called 9-1-1 and
they dispatched her because she was the
closest but since she doesn't know her
directions it took like three hours to
get there she got lost but it was two
blocks away okay three for three bar it
is she found some evidence while on duty
is like I'm gonna come back to this off
duty scoop this [ __ ] up like drugs or
money
get the diamonds in the police
department in the vent upstairs
or she she was off duty but she got up
in her outfit and she started pulling
over random people and she committed
Grand Theft Auto oh geez just to steal
cars this is still cars so who's the
closest uh you tell me who's the closest
I'll tell you really what happened she
was out
at a bar off duty okay had a few drinks
dude so I thought you might get it so I
thought did she lose her Direction at
any point you should get lost did it
take her three hours to get two blocks
while she was drunk I knew it you rock
the force she she gets drunk
leaves the bar
goes to Urban Outfitters and takes a
piss in the fitting room oh [ __ ] and
that's it dude oh she just needed to pee
that's all she did she just needed to oh
she thought she thought it was a
bathroom she thought it was the loo oh
sure you think she she mistakenly
thought it was the loop so in a way
Bart's kind of right she got lost she
didn't know where she was bro and she
started she started squatting on the
[ __ ] bench and she peed herself you
know so here's here's how it goes down
those fitting rooms look too much like
toilets and there's a mirror yeah you
know she goes into Urban Outfitters and
she asks him do you guys have a bathroom
they say that we do not she she goes
straight to the fitting room without
getting any clothes to try on she just
goes in it so then the employee like
gets like okay what the hell is this
calls the cops and then uh when um the
officer leaves she goes in there and she
says they're just piss everywhere oh she
just needed to pee and she drunk as [ __ ]
but here's where it gets bad it's not so
much that she did that it's that when
her Superior asks her what happened she
lied and said all I did was go in there
to adjust my bra because she was
embarrassed this is in the UK she's
embarrassed yeah she should come to the
States because she can keep her job if
she did it she'll get promoted she did
that promoted she'll get promoted this
would be not a new story this would this
would have been covered up no that's
commander-in-chief territory right there
and they would have paid her better
because cops in the UK don't get paid
and you get a gun dude you don't get a
gun over there you get a stupid [ __ ]
corn dog on a stick she comes up
we're giving me a [ __ ] tank okay what
what would you do in this situation
listen to the drinks she had okay I'm
gonna tell you her whole movie this is
everything she drinks there's a list
show the list itemize the list half a
bottle of Prosecco three cocktails a
Jack Daniels and a Coke and a second box
damn is she okay all in the space of
four hours that just sounds like a
British breakfast like they drink so
much out there
like everybody's an alcoholic there why
do you even take half a bottle of
Prosecco by itself though like what she
she was like I don't want this [ __ ]
anymore she got tired of drinking and
then she mixed it with Jack and Coke I
thought everybody knew Urban Outfitters
don't have public restrooms what time of
day was this it's like 2 p.m I don't
know the time of day it looks I think it
is it's daytime because if Urban offers
open right if there's an Urban
Outfitters there's a public restroom
close by yeah they're usually in like
big shopping centers my dude she's she's
she's not in the wrong she messes okay
always go to a McDonald's that's just
sad she just needed to pee like there
was one time while I was sitting in
traffic I can't believe I'm about to
tell the story I'm so happy you're about
to tell all the details we have time
this is the place everyone says I feel
hurt like I was sitting in traffic and I
needed to go
take a [ __ ] so bad okay we all raise the
stakes there's nothing new then what
happened I I was like just sitting
sitting in traffic and I was like oh I
think I can make it there so I called my
friend that I'm about to meet I'll be
like hey as soon as I get there I'm
going straight to the restroom leave the
door unlocked smart plan ahead right so
I'm sitting there for the bathroom and
it's like it's coming and I'm like to
the point where I'm shaking like I'm
sweating
like I'm I feel my whole body is like
literally just shaking is it diarrhea or
was it solid it's solid no spoilers
let's get there
what did you eat no because those are
different types of shakes yeah because
there's the diarrhea kind like because
the the solid one it's like sometimes
you can feel your skin ripping right
like it's like it's something
but you can also feel sometimes you
pushing it back in yeah yeah yeah yeah
but the diet you should head for that
the diarrhea one it's one of those it's
painful yeah you're like oh [ __ ] I'm
Gonna Keep squeezing but there's gonna
be a time there's no guarantee someone's
gonna pop the balloon okay so it was it
was a situation where it was like kind
of in the middle okay oh did you start
getting pale I I felt like I literally
just like started to block out because I
was like there's no way there's
literally no way you gotta do the
delivery breathe
I was literally doing that I can't
believe I was doing that I was like I'm
really going through this like as a full
grown adult I was like oh my God this is
crazy so I just I was sitting there in
traffic and I was like I can't I
literally can't
[ __ ] myself you had to you had to
like can I say something on record on
the freeway it's on the freeway
oh [ __ ] bro how come you didn't pull
over and just [ __ ] on the ground that
was the other way I was all the way to
the left bro I would rather [ __ ] myself
than pull over on the freeway and [ __ ]
on the ground
but that's different because like if
someone sees a guy shooting not gonna
care oh yeah yeah so I don't want to
soil myself I'd rather just go up and
just be like
just shooting on the call box yeah yeah
just [ __ ]
you could be like Bobby Lee and he went
in the back seat opened up the door and
shot through the back seat oh my God and
I don't even know why yeah but honestly
though like pooping your pants as an
adult is not that uncommon living in La
bro you know because you get why you got
to put a region on that
this is this is our La experience it's a
South L.A people yeah people in New York
can't relate to this okay that's true
it's because we're in traffic for like a
[ __ ] hour just sitting there
I just let it go and I just feel it like
just fill up my pants and I was like
wearing skinny jeans oh not anymore oh
my God and then I could I started to
smell it and I was like oh oh my God I
started to feel it like seep through to
my seat oh throw the car away and so I'm
like I'm going to I just exit I just
take the nearest exit I find a Starbucks
and I was like okay I'm gonna go in here
so I take like I I was in culinary
school at that time so I had like chef
pants so I just like take my chef pants
in there and then I thought they would
have a like a big trash can but they
didn't they had like those teeny tiny
small trash cans but whatever I took my
pants off cleaned myself
and then
my pants that's full of [ __ ] I had to
like fold it up and roll it and stuff it
into the little [ __ ] Hello Kitty
truck you just threw it away you have to
I was gonna take it home well if you had
some great jeans yeah that's true you've
been washing the sink maybe it can't be
saved bro I don't have any like plastic
paper or anything was it raw denim
I want to grab the liner from the trash
can
and just stole the [ __ ] back oh
there was no liner oh damn Starbucks
don't use them though yeah so I just
like stuffed my shitty pants into the
small ass trash can
um put on my regular chef pants and just
ordered us because I felt bad
whoever's cleaning that whoever's
cleaning that is like there's a poo poo
pants you know what's [ __ ] up about
Starbucks I'm sure that's not the first
time they see that on their regular bro
they see shitty yeah they're probably
like wow somebody took the time to roll
this
they cleaned it up oh These are nice
jeans what size are these I want some
poopy pants these ones are rolled up
they're nice
and then my car yeah we need to hear
about the car
um so rolled it up put in the Starbucks
trash can bought some black ice filled
it up I had a a towel that I just like
laid down and then when I got to my
friend's house we just we cleaned it but
the smell like it wouldn't come out for
like so you told your friend like hey I
had to actually when I when I did my
pants I called my friend back and was
like Hey and then he was like did you
poop your pants and I was like yeah how
did he know to Guess that well because I
told him that like I needed to use the
restroom really bad and so when I called
back he was like did you [ __ ] yourself
wow because it was like 50 minutes it
was all it was all in the first word
it's just
yeah
did it happen learning from you now I
think what I would do because you know
that in and when it's happening you're
not thinking clearly you know what
you're gonna do I don't know but now I'm
like you take the floor mat from the
bottom and then put it on the seat wow
wow that [ __ ] into the floor man you are
genius wow but that's because I'm
listening to your story slow down to
have time to think yeah in the moment
you're like oh I would never have
thought
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you look at your cup holder ah [ __ ] yeah
dude we're gonna see part of the Sun in
LA traffic [ __ ] on this [ __ ]
doormat dude he's gonna take his
doormat's gonna put on the floor of the
freeway come outside of his car
it's WeatherTech bro
foreign
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign